five years old and full of character
good boy
but life with frank isn't what kate had
imagined
the newborn she brought home from
hospital seemed a healthy baby boy but
he quickly stopped feeding and within
hours had had a seizure
doctors broke the news that her
three-day-old son was critically ill
with meningitis
the reason a group b strep infection and
the damage done would last a lifetime i
just remember feeling incredibly guilty
that it was an infection that i had
carried and that i'd passed on to frank
and also that i didn't know about it you
know i hadn't read enough i didn't
hadn't done enough research that was how
i remember feeling at the time
just really responsible for for passing
this on and not knowing
group b strep short for streptococcus is
a type of bacteria it's very common and
usually harmless
in fact between two and four in every 10
women carry it but there's a small risk
it can spread to the baby during labour
making them ill
that happens in about one in 1
750 pregnancies
and one baby a week dies as a result
with another surviving with a lifelong
disability
kate joined a support group campaigning
for all women to be screened for the
bacteria during pregnancy so antibiotics
can be given where necessary
as it stands the test is only available
privately
jane plum set up the group after her son
theo died when he was just 17 hours old
a trial is underway but 80 hospitals are
needed and so far only 30 have signed up
it really is a now or never
moment you know we've we've been uh
campaigning for preventing group b strap
infection in babies since 1990 1996
without having the robust evidence the
policy won't change and the gbs 3 trial
is absolutely the uk's best and probably
only shot at being able to get the
evidence
to affect change
frank has cerebral palsy and epilepsy as
a result of the infection despite that
he's thriving but frank's incredible and
amazing and we wouldn't change him for
the world it's just
it is difficult to know that this could
have been prevented
now katie is determined to see a time
when no other baby is put at risk
emma birchley sky news
well in response to that report the
government said there is currently
insufficient evidence regarding the
benefits of universal screening we keep
this evidence under review and we'll
consider the results of an ongoing
large-scale clinical trial when it
reports